sí
bienvenido a pixar en esta lección
aprenderás a articular personajes
si tomaste la lección de animación ya
aprendiste cómo crear una actuación
animada de una pelota rebotando tenemos
los controles que te permitieron mover
la pelota de un lugar a otro o estirarla
así o comprimir la de esta forma estas
transformaciones se definen con
distintos tipos de de formadores por
ejemplo un de formador de rotación te
permite girar la pelota un deformador de
traslación te permite mover el balón en
cualquier dirección y un informador de
escala puede usarse para comprimir el
balón cuando llega al piso de terminar y
crear estos de formadores es el trabajo
de un articulador es bastante sencillo
cuando se trata de una pelota se vuelve
más complicado cuando se habla de un
coche y un bebé humano es realmente
difícil
como puedes ver estoy parado junto a
esta lámpara gigante que aparece en
luxor juniors uno de los primeros
cortometrajes realizados en pixar
aunque las lámparas son sólo objetos
sólidos sin movimiento o emociones
propias un joven animador llamado john
lasseter creyó que podría convertirla en
un actor el vio como esta lámpara podría
convertirse en un personaje realista se
le dio una articulación simple que
consistía desde formadores que podían
rotar trasladar y escalar la lámpara en
1986 un artista de articulación llamado
ébano y tuvo que trabajar muy duro para
crear el software que podría articular
la lámpara y así permitirle a jon crear
su actuación animada en el resto de esta
lección tendrás oportunidad de crear el
articulado que nos permitirá animar
nuestra lámpara antes de articular
nuestra lámpara necesitamos examinar la
de cerca observarás que consta de una
base de una parte central y una cabeza
de lámpara estos elementos están
conectados mediante articulaciones que
giran puedes ver que un de formador de
rotación moverá la articulación
haciéndola girar y hay una dependencia
de las otras articulaciones sobre esa
rotación la dependencia de una parte
sobre la otra es lo que llamamos una
jerarquía y es nuestro trabajo como
articuladores determinar las
características de esa jerarquía de
manera que cuando una articulación gire
todas las demás partes las sigan en este
primer ejercicio articularemos nuestra
lámpara con las rotaciones sencillas de
las que hablamos anteriormente aranza
esto arrastrándolos de formadores de
rotación hasta cada una de las
articulaciones con sólo cuatro
rotaciones es posible crear poses que
expresan una amplia gama de emociones y
acciones nosotros solemos probar una
articulación creando un número de poses
que muestren lo que puede hacer
y esas personas son articuladores
también